last video was a big long rundown of the
various editing problems that plagued
Warner Brothers films Suicide Squad and
the comments got there there's a lot of
them first thing a correction fox is the
studio responsible for fan-forced ik not
Sony this was purely an error on my part
I I got a brain cloud though in my
defense I ran the script by a number of
people and none of them caught it either
because it's just that believable that
Sony would also produce something like
fan for stick to be clear fox holds the
film rights for Fantastic Four x-men and
Deadpool while Sony holds the rights to
spider-man which you know hasn't exactly
been stellar these days either second
the fate of griggs in the video I
highlight that the chief security guard
Griggs is overdeveloped in the front
half the movie but disappears after this
interaction with Harley as the squatter
being loaded onto a plane for Midway
City a lot of people popped into the
comments to mention that Griggs is seen
again being tortured by Joker and this
is to me actually a great illustration
of how bad the overall structure of the
movie is that so many people would in
retrospect be unable to accurately place
the scene order so the scene that people
are referring to is this one where Joker
threatens Griggs and it cuts away before
we find out what Joker wants or plans
but this scene actually comes much
earlier in fact it's way back before
enchantress even breaks her brother out
in that scene Griggs presumably gets the
cell phone that he later gives to Harley
and then after the that he's never seen
again now a few people suggested that
he's in the helicopter when Harley
escapes working the minigun but that's
just another one of Joker's henchmen
so Griggs is seen interacting with the
inmates during all of the repetitive
introductions then he goes to the casino
where he's intercepted by Joker's gang
and finally he gives the cell to Harley
and then he's never seen again
third another small correction trailer
park is the company that Warner Brothers
reportedly got to do an alternate
competing cut of the movie however their
prior involvement was actually the 2015
Comic Con sneak preview and not the
Bohemian Rhapsody trailer like I said in
the video that trailer the theatrical
trailer and all the TV spots were cut by
another company aspect so the confusion
is the trailer park was brought in to
make a full cut more along the lines of
the trailers that were cut by aspect
fourth the bottle was cough syrup and it
was full of water or was it it was water
lastly a note on the difference between
structural editing problems and script
problems how do you tell if something is
poorly edited or if it was forced that
way by poor writing this is a
legitimately difficult thing to reverse
engineer out of a finished film unless
you have access to the shooting script
so for the purpose of analysis
it's an editing problem if the material
exists but is in the wrong order and
it's a scripting problem if the material
doesn't exist at all so for example the
flash cameo sequence in Batman V
Superman is ultimately pointless and
confusing focusing on oblique franchise
building rather than any sort of
character plot development relative to
the actual movie so while that's a
script problem because they wrote it
that way
it's more pertinently an editing problem
because the editor should have dropped
it
these are interlocking problems though
suicide squads poor pace is a direct
consequence of poor writing because all
the characters were written in they're
compartmentalized bits it's really hard
for the editors to make that move at a
good pace to reiterate from the longer
breakdown a more coherent cut of the
film almost certainly exists but it
would be an incredibly long slow-moving
cut of the film as well with even more
time dedicated to backstories and time
in prison something that already takes
up almost half of the runtime and that's
it for this week please like share and
subscribe and if you'd like to call me a
beta SJW [ __ ] Marvel fanboy you're
probably already typing that into the
comments let's be honest
[Music]